peter thiel has mixed feelings about
monopolies he thinks entrepreneurs
should aim to build a monopoly if they
want to be really successful
i have a single e-day fix that i'm
completely obsessed with on the business
side which is that if you're starting a
company
you always want to aim for monopoly and
you want to always avoid
competition hence competition is for
losers but he's also called google out
for being a monopoly
there are obviously individual companies
that do uh
quite well especially if they have you
know world-class monopolies like google
has in search
legal monopolies they're legal as long
as they don't try to tie in
and oppress other companies by extending
the monopoly power unfairly
but it's uh it's it's quite legal to
have a monopoly as long as you don't
abuse it
and recently he's been funding
politicians who are bringing anti-trust
lawsuits against big tech monopolies
google has now been hit with its third
anti-trust
lawsuit in just a few months this one is
coming from
it's being led by the colorado attorney
general and a group of 38 states and
territory the suit claims that google
we've heard this before has illegally
maintained a monopoly in general search
and search advertising through
anti-competitive conducts and contracts
i'm john coogan and this is my deep dive
into technology monopolies
today i'm going to try and answer a few
questions that have been bouncing around
the tech community
first i want to explain what a monopoly
is and why monopolies are illegal in the
first place
then i want to examine big tech
companies and quantitatively assess
whether they fit the traditional
definition of monopolies as well as look
at how things have changed over time
lastly i want to talk about the
political considerations here
and how entrepreneurs should think about
the issue of antitrust
a monopoly exists when one company
controls the entire supply of a given
product
there is a consensus among economists
that monopolies create sub-optimal
outcomes
this is because when companies use
monopoly power to raise prices
customers have no choice but to pay the
higher price this creates lost
economic efficiency and will hurt gdp
growth in the long run if left unchecked
antitrust laws are the us government's
primary tool for breaking out monopolies
and the foundation of antitrust
enforcement is the sherman antitrust act
of 1890
in the late 19th century industrial
monopolies were rampant
so u.s senator john sherman proposed
legislation that would allow the
government to break up monopolies
when they were found to be hurting the
american economy the legislation became
an important tool in the coming years
with presidents theodore roosevelt and
william taft
using the sherman antitrust act to
regulate or break up a number of
american businesses
including standard oil but much of the
modern theory around antitrust
is actually informed by louis brandeis a
supreme court justice who served from
1916
until 1939. while he was a justice
brandeis referred to the problems caused
by monopolies as
the curse of bigness and wrote that
monopolies are secured by
cutthroat competition espionage doing
business as fake independence
and the making of exclusive contracts
brandeis created an entire school of
thought around monopolies that lives on
today
one of his core theories was that the
concentration of economic power
aids the concentration of political
power and that such private power
can itself undermine and overwhelm
public government
he also notably believed that the
structure of our markets
and of our economy can determine how
much real liberty
individuals experience in their daily
lives most americans have much less
interaction with the government on a
daily basis
as opposed to the private companies they
purchase things from
or do business with so companies with
monopoly power can seriously limit
american liberty in a very tangible way
but brandeis isn't the only influence
when it comes to monopolies
robert bork was a judge and legal
scholar who championed the so-called
chicago school of antitrust analysis
in his 1978 book the antitrust paradox
bork argued that consumer welfare should
be the sole standard for antitrust law
nothing else matters both brandeis and
bork remain
important figures in antitrust debates
with left-leaning politicians usually
citing brandeis
and right-leaning politicians often
citing borg
all this political history became a lot
more relevant a few weeks ago
when the biden administration picked tim
wu as an advisor on technology and
competition
wu has published several books about
antitrust and has specifically focused
on
the concentrated power held by
technology companies in his 2018 book
the curse of bigness wu argues as
brandeis did nearly a century ago
that extreme economic concentration
yields gross inequality and material
suffering
feeding an appetite for nationalistic
and extremist leadership
it's not just the democrats who are
pushing antitrust actions forward
against big tech though
republican josh hawley who's now a
senator launched an investigation into
google back in 2018.
hawley is significant in all of this
because he received political funding
from none other than peter thiel
who has been vocal for nearly a decade
about google's monopoly on search
so let's dig into the monopoly question
a bit more starting with google
who's clearly the biggest target here
google is under fire for two main
reasons
first is that they have the largest
market share in their primary business
of all the major tech firms here's a
chart of how dominant each tech company
is
in its primary market google is clearly
leading with 88
market share in search engines zooming
out people looking to answer the
question
is this particular industry monopolistic
often we'll look at the revenue share of
the top four firms
in a particular industry and looking at
that data for the tech industry
you can see that the tech sector is
indeed the most concentrated
of all the major american industries but
it can be extremely difficult to
objectively assess
market concentration for one major
reason how do you define a particular
market
it's true that google is dominant in
search but they are clearly in fierce
competition with facebook for
advertising dollars
if you instead look at the advertising
market over the past five years
you will see that google's market share
has remained fairly constant
the same is true for other tech sub
sectors like app stores
cloud payments business software and
gaming
increasingly the big tech companies are
bumping into each other with every new
initiative they launch
consider google facebook amazon and
apple
they each operate primarily in separate
markets search
social commerce and devices each company
has significant control over its primary
market
but if you follow new product
announcements and acquisitions closely
you will see that they are all in direct
competition google has youtube to
compete in social android nest and
chromecast to compete in devices
and google shopping to compete in
commerce facebook has portal and oculus
to compete in devices
marketplace to compete with amazon and
commerce and they've been growing the
facebook search function to compete with
google
apple uses imessage to compete with
facebook in social
they have siri which can route around
google for search traffic
and they are growing apple pay to expand
into commerce
lastly amazon has a growing ad network
that competes with google
they bought twitch which competes in
social and they have a wide array of
alexa-powered devices that compete with
apple products
increasingly tech companies are
diversifying and competing with each
other
which should benefit the consumer and
data suggests that this is working
the majority of americans still have
highly favorable opinions about big tech
companies
and we haven't seen cases where tech
companies are raising prices
and harming consumers so why do
republicans and democrats both seem
interested in breaking up these big tech
companies
even though both political parties want
to reduce the power of big tech
they have very different motivations and
it all comes back to brandeis and bork
let's take a look at what democratic
congressman david cecilini had to say
about the motivations on the left
because concentrated economic power also
leads to concentrated political power
this investigation also goes to the
heart of whether we
as a people govern ourselves or whether
we let ourselves be governed by private
monopolies
american democracy has always been at
war against monopoly power
throughout our history we've recognized
that concentrated markets
and concentrated political control are
incompatible with democratic ideals
when the american people confronted
monopolists in the past be it the
railroads or the oil tycoons or at t
and microsoft we took action to ensure
no private corporation
controls our economy or our democracy
solely is making
a clear call back to brandeis here and
the idea that monopolies will inevitably
convert their vast economic power into
political power
even though the tech companies are
mostly aligned with democrats at the
moment
that could easily shift so it's in the
interest of government representatives
to curb the political influence of tech
companies before it's too late
republicans are more focused on borch's
idea of economic harm to the american
consumer
essentially even if google does have a
monopoly on search
that's fine as long as they don't use it
to raise prices
for years google has had an easy answer
to this line of questioning
google search is free to the end user so
the price gouging question is
moot but republicans have warmed up to
the idea of regulating tech companies
because conservative content has been
severely penalized on the internet
republican representative matt gates
articulated at this point well
but i want to talk about search because
that's an area where i know google has
real market dominance on december 11th
you testified
to the judiciary committee and in
response to a question from my colleague
zoe lofgren
about search you said we don't manually
intervene on any particular search
result
but leaked memos obtained by the daily
caller show
that that isn't true in fact those memos
were altered
december 3rd just a week before your
testimony and they describe
a deceptive news blacklist and a process
for developing that black
list approved by ben gomes who leads
search with your company
and also something called a a fringe
ranking
which seems to beg the question you know
who gets to decide
what's fringe so even the republicans
are generally okay with the economic
activity of big tech companies they are
increasingly worried about the ability
of tech companies to swing elections by
limiting the spread of conservative
content online
and this really gets to the heart of the
issue in my mind democrats blame big
tech for helping get donald trump
elected in 2016
and republicans blame big tech for
helping joe biden defeat him in 2020.
it's a lose-lose situation for tech
companies which is why you see companies
like facebook now
asking for regulation around political
content circling back to peter thiel
though what does this all mean for
entrepreneurs
well i think teel's advice still rings
true disruptive startups are rarely
built in highly competitive markets
it's much better to find a new industry
that hasn't really been explored yet
than try to compete in a crowded space
and with that
i'll leave you with one closing thought
directly from teal himself
i would say that uh don't always go
through the tiny little door that
everyone's trying to rush through
maybe go around the corner and go
through the vast gate that no one's
taking